joe biden continues to malfunction on
the public stage as vladimir putin makes
his aggressive intentions clear
and china demonstrates once again they
can't be trusted i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment now you may have noticed that
we are in a
significant state of economic turmoil
here in the united states that the
government is pumping
money into the system that inflation is
running at crazy
rates right now and you might think to
yourself how do i diversify how do i
protect my assets especially when my
assets are depreciating if i just keep
them
in the bank and the answer is at least
get some of your money into precious
metals in april alone consumer prices
increased by 4.2 percent that's the
biggest bump
since 2008 with higher fuel prices and
higher food prices and construction
costs and housing prices
inflation is already here and again you
need to talk to my friends over at birch
gold to help fight it
if you have not reached out to birch
gold to diversify part of your ira or
401k into a precious metals ira
do it today text ben 247 4747
get a free information kit on protecting
your savings with gold i buy my gold
from birch gold they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless 5 star reviews over 10
thousand happy customers
talk to them have them help you
safeguard your investments again
it's just a smart thing to diversify at
least part of your portfolio in a
precious metals diversification it's a
smart investment strategy and with
inflation kicking in
precious metals should be part of that
portfolio text ben's 47 47 47 when you
make a purchase before june 30th
birch gold will send you a signed copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps
for free while supplies last again text
my name ben to 47 47 47
protect your savings today all right
we're going to get to the news
in just one second first exciting
announcement daily wire has several open
positions for our in-house team
in nashville in particular we are
looking for a paid media buyer for the
paid media division of our marketing
department
to create and execute paid media
campaigns for daily wire for this
position
we need someone who has strong skills
with organization time management
attention to detail
at least one year of previous
professional experience in a paid media
buyer or similar role and excel
proficiency required as well
this is an in-office position in
nashville tennessee apply through
dailywire.com
queers and by the way check out all of
our careers at dailywire.com careers if
you wish to get involved with this
magnificent
company alrighty well we begin with the
simple fact that joe biden
is slated to meet vladimir putin and um
things are not going to go well this is
my prediction
according to yahoo news president biden
agrees with russian president vladimir
putin on at least one thing
relations between their two nations are
currently at a very low ebb
now my favorite way that that is that is
sort of phrased is the suggestion that
they have been at high ebb in the recent
past you may have remembered
that george w bush once said that he
looked into vladimir putin's eyes and
saw his soul
and relations didn't end up being very
good and then barack obama was like
i think we can do business you and me
i'll give you some flexibility
and then things didn't end up going very
well and then donald trump took a
harsher position with the russians but
was currently
it was simultaneously being accused of
being a sort of
russian stooge and it turns out
relations weren't that great it turns
out it's very difficult
to have excellent relations with a
dictatorial murderer like vladimir putin
i mean just baseline very rough rough
stuff right
but apparently joe biden and vladimir
putin agree on one thing and that is
that donald trump is a very bad orange
man who's bad
and orange as well both said as much in
interviews leading up to wednesday's
meeting in geneva which comes amid
tensions over myriad issues including a
spate of cyber attacks emanating from
within russia
putin's military adventurism along his
country's border with ukraine
and his imprisonment of opposition
leader alexi navalny who survived
poisoning with a russian nerve agent
according to yahoo news biden arrives at
the summit fresh
from enthusiastic meetings with allies
welcoming the return of the united
states to conventional
multilateral diplomacy he aims to use
that support to present a unified front
to challenge putin that's a weird way of
putting it considering that
in the recent past joe biden has
basically greenlit the nordstrom 2
pipeline which is going to
wildly enrich russia and also saying
that he's arriving fresh from anywhere
is uh is a bit of a malaprop considering
that joe biden has not been fresh for
night on 45 years
i mean that fish has been rotten for for
quite a while and
that simple fact is demonstrative of
sort of where we stand
in terms of global politics right now
the rest of the world is looking at the
united states and they are seeing easy
pickings right now
that's just the reality the reality is
that donald trump for all of his foibles
was considered prickly he was considered
unpredictable he himself said
i like to be sort of predictably
unpredictable right i don't want them to
know what i'm thinking and nobody knew
what he was thinking i mean to his
credit
people didn't know whether he was gonna
hug them or they was gonna fire some
sort of
missile at them and that's not a
terrible thing okay with joe biden
everybody sort of knows what they're
going to get
which is a little bit of talk and not
much action the russians know this
vladimir putin isn't
being shy about any of this not only
that vladimir putin
understands enough about the american
left to understand that if he just
mirrors the arguments of the american
left there's not much they can do about
it
now this was a common tactic during the
soviet union during the soviet union
the soviet union would be criticized for
you know slaughtering 20 million of its
own people
or keeping 100 million people under the
boot heel of a totalitarian regime
or taking over eastern europe or funding
communist insurgencies around the world
ending with the murder of tens of
thousands of human beings and they get
these sort of critiques every so often
using rare from the left but sometimes
and their usual response would be
ah yes but you two have sinned ah yes
but look at race relations in the united
states ah yes
but look at the united states where
cruel exploitation
has led to capitalistic poverty and the
less would be like that's true
oh my god i never thought of it that's
so true we are
we maybe we are the bad guys so vladimir
putin
trained in the kgb and so he uses these
exact same tactics
all the time and he says stuff he knows
that the american left will agree with
so he makes the same critics of the
united states the blm makes
he makes the critical race theory
arguments that the left in the united
states likes to make
and so he will deflect any criticism and
all criticism simply by talking about
the weaknesses of the united states
which
with which the left largely agrees here
is vladimir putin for example deflecting
criticism by saying january 6th he said
we have a saying don't be mad at the
mural if you're ugly
points honestly points for being a bond
villain from vladimir putin i've said it
before the man is just an excellent bond
villain he says it has nothing to do
with you personally but if somebody
blames us for something what i say is
why don't you look at yourself
you'll see ourselves in the mirror not
us
i we have much in common mr bond it's
every vladimir putin's speech he said
did you order an assassination of the
woman who walked into congress and was
shot and killed by policemen
he's talking about ashley babbitt he
says do you know 450 individuals were
arrested after entering congress
they didn't go there to steal laptop
they came with political demands right
so now he's
he is suggesting that the crackdown on
people who invaded the capital building
is sort of like
the crackdown on you know just peaceful
dissenters in russia who have been
imprisoned on mass their protests broken
up and all the rest right so this is the
game
that vladimir putin loves to play and
vladimir putin also at the same time
will not commit
to human rights in his own country
because why would he hell's the point
he's been there for 20 years i mean
who's going to who's going to do
something about it is vladimir putin's
point of view
so putin for example was asked about
whether alexi navalny who is this
russian dissident
who has basically been falsely
imprisoned in russia whether
he is going to leave prison alive
because he's very sick putin
allegedly tried to poison him a while
back he got very sick recovered
now he's in prison in russia because he
landed in russia they immediately
grabbed him and threw him in prison and
now he is like
on his deathbed and here's putin being
going full ivan drago if he dies he dies
will you commit that you will personally
ensure
that alexi navolni will leave prison
alive
i proceed from the premise that the
person that you have mentioned
the same kind of measures will apply not
in any way worse than
to anybody else who happens to be
in prison his name is alexey navalny
people will note that you
i don't care i don't care he would
and he doesn't care again bond villain
okay so we're going to get to more of
this in just one second and then we'll
get to the president of the united
states who's supposed to stand up to
this guy
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that now is an excellent
time to get life insurance why because
every time is an excellent time to get
life insurance if you are a responsible
person go get the life insurance your
family needs god forbid something should
happen to you they're not just gonna
miss you they're gonna miss your stream
of income there's no reason they should
miss both
go check out life insurance right now
and save on it when you go to
policygenius.com
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all
in one place why compare well you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius it
could save 1300 bucks or more per year
on life insurance by using policy genius
to compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius and excellent rating on
trustpilot getting started super simple
first head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling for
free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies they
don't add on extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice
and very very important to get it right
okay so
meanwhile vladimir putin not only is he
engaging in this sort of gamesmanship he
also suggested
publicly that the kremlin has never been
engaged in any of these sort of
hacks against american targets no no no
never i mean no and also all the real
human rights violations are happening of
course
in the united states of course that's
really the problem
meanwhile it turns out that vladimir
putin has been ordering the largest
military exercises in the pacific since
the
end of the cold war oh he's not being
confrontational or anything guys
everything's going great
according to the daily star in the uk
vladimir putin's forces have been
spotted hunting an enemy
submarine fake enemy summary with 20
surface ships submarines and supporting
vessels all playing their part in the
largest scale naval exercise since the
fall of the soviet union
the russian president will meet u.s
counterparty obadon on june 16th putin
was not afraid to show his military
might just days before the meeting
a total of 20 warplanes took to the
skies including
tu-142 m3 long-range anti-submarine
aircraft
mig-31 bm high-altitude interceptor
fighters and a selection of other
aircraft belonging to russia's aerospace
force according to tass
in a video put out by russia's ministry
of defense the flute can be seen in
pursuit of and quote unquote driving out
a mock
enemy submarine a moscow defense
ministry statement said during the
exercise the crews
of the pacific fleet's warships fired
from the automatic naval gun mounts
ak-630 and the universal naval artillery
a190 so obviously
vladimir putin trying to flex his
muscles meanwhile joe biden has no
muscles to flex
and this is the biggest problem joe
biden is not
all there now theoretically he could be
not all there but his team could be
staffed by a bunch of hawks who really
are going to face up to the threat that
russia poses
and remember according to the democrats
until the last 35 seconds
when joe biden became president russia
was the chief threat to the united
states
now they said that of course because
they were focused in
over and over and over on the idea that
donald trump was somehow being bribed to
be president by vladimir putin he was a
manchurian candidate
or the moscow candidate but now that
biden's president
they're like you know what it would be
great if we cut our military and you
know what if we put out some like
recruiting videos for the military that
featured lesbian moms i mean that seems
like a great way to recruit for the
military and for the cia what if we like
really targeted the group of people who
are thinking about applying to the cia
but
suffer from generalized anxiety disorder
that that's like that's where we got to
put our time
and our effort and also we really have
to consider whether military bases
should fly the pride flag i mean these
are really
important subjects for the united states
military in the face of increased
russian aggression and meanwhile you've
got that administration topped
by a person whose brain is just not
functioning okay i'm sorry
the media are not going to show you
these clips they will not show you these
clips on cbs evening news because they
are extremely disquieting
and honestly you have to feel bad for
the president of the united states who
at this point
seems to be the victim of elder abuse
they're trotting out a person who he
does not have his faculties about him
if you've ever had an elderly relative
who's starting to lose it joe biden is
your elder elderly relative who is
starting to lose it i actually feel bad
for the man he is in a high-pressure
situation the highest pressure job on
planet earth and he is clearly not
capable of handling himself
it's honestly he's my president too
right he's your president
he's the elected president you don't
want the elected president to not have
the ability to even speak
here was joe biden yesterday i mean
there's an unbelievable clip
here is joe biden yesterday asked about
whether vladimir putin is a killer now
he to preface this clip to backtrack for
a moment
understand that in march joe biden did
an interview in which he was asked
whether vladimir putin was a killer and
he said
absolutely here was joe biden just a
couple of months ago saying that
vladimir putin was a killer
most important thing dealing with
foreign leaders in my experience and
i've dealt with an awful lot of
my career is just know the other guy
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer
i do okay so pretty swift answer there
with his good friend george
stephanopoulos here was yesterday okay
remember this has only been a three
month gap
this is this is a guy in a serious state
of mental decline i mean
i don't know what else to tell you i'm
only looking at the evidence in my eyes
i'm not a doctor i'm not gonna pretend
i'm a doctor
all i can tell you is that if you've
ever seen a person who is sliding
down the hill in terms of his faculties
joe biden looks an awful lot like that
remember that was him with george
stephanopoulos
in march here is don here is president
joe biden
in june being asked the same question
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually i
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was
there certain things that he would do or
did do
but look when i was asked that question
on air i answered it honestly but it's
not
much of a i i i don't think it matters a
whole lot in terms of this next meeting
we're about to have
okay first of all very weak answer but
second of all
that is a full six and a half second gap
in that tape
where he's just standing there not
knowing what's going on around him
okay that guy is going to stand up to a
kgb train killer like vladimir putin
i hope he does he's my president too
again i would love to see the presidents
of the united states take a hard
strong stance with regards to the
russians i just don't think it's going
to happen
and joe biden was also asked by the way
about russia and
and he referred to russia as quote
unquote our adversary and
or our possible adversary again it's
just
that he is he is now arnold
schwarzenegger in total recall
wearing the the lady disguise when it
starts to glitch
i mean you're afraid that his head is
going to start opening up right that's
that's what he's going to start shaking
all over the place and then he's going
to explode into arnold schwarzenegger
it's so weird here here's the president
of the united states
i've been doing this a long time yes you
have the last thing
anyone would do is negotiate in front of
the world press
as to how he's going to approach a
critical meeting
with another adversary and or
someone who could be an adversary that's
the last thing i'm going to do
that's the yes great okay well meanwhile
china is on the move as well biden's
being tested
so far not seen a lot from joe biden
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about safety and security at
your home there are a thousand reasons
why protecting my home matters to me
in fact i have three excellent reasons
why protecting my home it matters to me
they're my three
young children they're running around
the house all the time i got to keep an
eye on them
and one of the great things about ring
is that i can just open up my phone i
can see what they are doing
at my house at any time i can make sure
that they are doing okay
and if somebody stops by something's
going on outdoors around the house ring
will let me know it's peace of mind
anytime knowing my home is protected to
get ring alarm for yourself
go to ring.com ben it's the perfect way
to start your ring experience
the thing i enjoy most besides ring
being a powerful asset for my home ring
is also an affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself
and it's never been more important to be
able to see who's there or what's
happening anytime around the house
inside or outside
i can see it all in one simple app with
ring my family and i keep an eye on our
home no matter where we are right from
our phone start protecting your home
today with ring alarm go to ring.com
get your ring alarm security kit today
you can build the system that is right
for your home have it up and running in
just minutes when my wife and i moved
from california to florida first thing
we did we put the ring alarm system on
our house
makes us feel more secure you should do
the same ring.com
that is ring.com ben to get your ring
alarm security
kit today alrighty so meanwhile the
chinese government
is also getting more and more aggressive
so apparently
the chinese government is now engaging
in serious harassment around taiwan
according to newsweek the chinese
government has now activated a swarm of
warplanes around
taiwan after the g7 and nato talked up
the threat of china newsweek says over a
dozen more planes that took off from
china and triggered radar stations in
taiwan early tuesday
as military aircraft once again swarmed
the island's air defense zone following
more than a week of relative quiet
radio intercepts sent to newsweek
included at least 17 airborne warnings
aimed
at pla warplanes the warnings were
broadcast by republic of china air force
radio operators between 5 48 am and 10
43 am local time the precise number of
intruding aircraft was initially unclear
the office of taiwan's ministry of
national defense spokesperson declined
to comment on these developments the
department later announced
it had detected 28 chinese military
planes that is a single day record
apparently the large incursion into the
southwest corner of taiwan's adiz
comes after 10 days of relative quiet
with just one pla asset detected in the
area since june 4th
a y-8 anti-submarine war warfare
aircraft spotted on monday
the chinese military's return to gray
zone activity around taiwan follows
biden's attendance of key summits with
g7 and nato allies both of which
resulted in firm rebukes of beijing's
actions across
various sectors now understand this is
not about china's about to invade taiwan
and what this is about is intimidating
all of the border countries around china
into understanding
that if they push china too hard china
will push back
and not only will they push back they
understand that the west isn't going to
do anything about it
monday's nato's joint statement
highlighted china's ambitions and
assertive behavior but they agreed to do
nothing
they didn't agree to anything biden led
g7 leaders in a communique that included
several direct and indirect mentions of
china pushing beijing for cooperation on
covet 19 origin tracing fair
fair trade practices and human rights
but um they're not going to do anything
again there will be nothing done
and that is really what matters in
foreign policy it's not these these
empty statements that everybody knows
are empty it's where they're going to do
anything
and understand china like russia is not
an accelerating power china is a
declining power china has serious
problems
china because it's one child policy has
gone into steep population decline which
is why they've now said
that people in china should have three
kids after engaging in the murder of
literally hundreds of millions of
children over the course of the last
three decades they've now reversed
themselves because they've completely
demographically wiped themselves off the
map
not only that their economy is not
nearly what it is supposed to be
it is predicated heavily on taking out
foreign debt
it is predicated on being able to cram
down particularly in rural areas misery
on its own citizens
it's a china remains a totalitarian
slave state for a large number of its
citizens
okay and not only that they're supposed
to technological prowess you read in the
thomas freeman wow thomas friedman has
written
about how china is creating new
high-speed rail okay the reality is that
china's infrastructure sucks okay
they have a few nice things and a lot of
really bad things it's sort of like how
the soviet union
used to have these show pieces these are
potemkin villages where they would bring
the westerners
oh look is this nice china is a little
bit better because they actually do have
some serious major cities
but i understand that in a country of a
billion people a huge number of those
people are living
in serious poverty right those like by
american standards
true abject poverty not only that their
their
facilities are just not all that great i
mean right now we have a report
that you know you thought that the
woohen lab was was china's chernobyl
nope it turns out that china's chernobyl
is china's chernobyl according to cnn
the us government has spent the past
week assessing a report of a leak at a
chinese nuclear power plant after a
french company that part owns and helps
operate it warned
of an imminent radiological threat
according to u.s officials and documents
reviewed by cnn the warning included an
accusation that the chinese safety
authority was
was raising the acceptable limits for
radiation detection outside the taishan
nuclear power plant in guangdong
province in order to avoid having to
shut it down
and so they're they're going full scale
communist authoritarian state
oh you know we're letting off too much
radiation i have an idea what if we just
call it not too much radiation
and this is their idea this is what
they're doing so there's a leak that's
happening basically
and the chinese government's like
instead of defining it as a leak what if
we just pretended it wasn't the leak
how about that despite the alarming
notification that
phramatom the french company the biden
administration believes the facility is
not yet at a crisis level according to
one of the sources
u.s officials have deemed the situation
does not currently pose a severe safety
threat to workers at the plant or the
chinese public
but it is unusual that a foreign company
would unilaterally reach out to the
american government for help
when its chinese state-owned partner has
yet to acknowledge a problem exists
the scenario could put the us in a
complicated situation should the leak
continue
or become more severe without being
fixed um
well why i mean is it possible that the
reason that the french company is coming
to the us is because the chinese are
hiding this
because this is what the chinese
government does the chinese government
by the way continues
to play down the possibility of a
serious
lab leak in fact one of the scientists
from china has now said no no no no
there's no lab leak here
there's nothing to see she said hell on
earth can i offer up evidence for
something where there is no evidence
she said i don't know how the world has
come to this constantly pouring filth on
an innocent scientist
she announced the suspicions as baseless
as what chinese bat woman right she
works at the wuhan lab
including the allegations that several
of her colleagues may have been ill
before the outbreak emerged
um i don't believe you in the words of
anchorman i don't believe you
and i don't believe you because you have
not demonstrated any sort of
trustworthiness
by the way i say not demonstrating any
sort of trustworthiness remember china
rolled out its quote-unquote cinepharm
vaccine
for covet-19 it sucked so badly that
countries that have used it are seeing
massive spikes in kovid so china
is in a state of decay which makes it
more aggressive russia in a state of
decay makes it more aggressive
and we have a president in the state of
decay and uh that is no good
okay in just a second we're going to get
to what is truly occupying
the us government at this point you know
the important things first
let's talk about how you protect
yourself and your family so owning a
firearm is great
it is i own several of them but it's not
enough if god forbid somebody breaks
into your house
you want to be able to defend yourself
but you also want to have you know some
form of actual protection
and this is why body armor can be a
really really good idea there's a pretty
good chance if you're listening to this
program you own a firearm
or even if you don't you still care
about protecting yourself your family
and your second amendment rights you may
not know it but the second amendment
protects your right to own ballistic
body armor as well as a firearm
air 500 armor has been selling body
armor to citizens just
like you for nine years and has made it
easy affordable and approachable
get twenty percent off your first order
by texting ben to eight eight zero two
seven or going to ar500 armor.com
ben they have loadouts designed for
everyone whether you need a concealable
vest for daily use a plate carrier for
the range
or a fully equipped setup for the worst
case scenario
and if you're unsure what type of armor
is right for you you have questions you
can contact their team they're always
happy to assist and they have an
independence day sale going on right now
the sales are up to 50 off select
products so go get them while they last
they have rifle rated bundles
starting as low as 99 text been to 88027
to see all their promotions and special
pricing running right now you can use
codebend for 20
off anything in their entire store and
best of all they've put together some
packages specifically for my listeners
here at the daily wire so there's
something for everyone ar500 armor.com
textband 28027 for 20 off your very
first order okay
meanwhile we are focusing in on the
important things here in the united
states
not foreign threats come on not not
rising world powers that are that are
threatening
people around their borders and hacking
american systems
and stealing american technology and
undermining the world
economy and threatening trade routes no
no we have our priorities
our priorities are the progress pride
flag the interior department yesterday
on flag days yesterday was flag day
flag day celebrates the the adoption of
the
original american flag in 1777 so on
flag day
it was time to adopt a new flag over at
the interior department deb holland
put up the so-called progress pride flag
so this is a flag that we probably
aren't all that familiar with
the classical pride flag was just the
rainbow flag right well now
you have the the it is a truly hideous
flag you have the pro just on an
aesthetic level the progress
pride flag which has a bunch of new
stripes coming in from the side
in an arrow formation pushing across
the original pride flag and this
includes transgender
and intersex and and all sorts of uh all
sorts of stripes for for different
people because flags don't unify anymore
you have to have an individual
flag stripe on the flag that represents
your identity
personally it doesn't represent you know
like a state like a star would
right because that is a body politic no
it represents you personally on the flag
and and this is now being flown over
government buildings because obviously
it unifies all americans
all of these issues are truly unifying
to all americans so
deb halland tweeted out today we
celebrate love for the first time ever
the progress pride flag is raised over
the interior department
happy pride again imagine that when
donald trump was president he just
decided to raise up
a giant flag of a cross over a
government building and said
you know happy religious freedom day
america you think people have been okay
with that
and yet this is totally fine these are
the issues that we're focused on they're
the most important issues
in america today and in fact it is
the most important issues are
recognizing that america is a system of
privilege
that must be revolutionized from within
it is a constant
ongoing revolution and if you notice the
revolution then you're the bad guy
if you notice that there is an active
attempt by folks on the left to
undermine traditional american values
you're the bad guy if you point out that
the left seems
wildly focused on an identity politics
that
suggests that america's institutions are
not only rife with racism but rooted in
racism
and inextricably intertwined with racism
if you notice that they are pushing this
actively
then this means that you are the bad guy
tara mcauliffe the
former virginia governor and current
virginia gubernatorial candidate
he's back and he is saying you know all
these right-wingers who are focused in
on critical race theory these days i
don't know why they're focused in on
critical race theory these days even
though we are now adopting
the tenets of critical race theory into
nearly every aspect of american
education and government
no no no if you're if you're noticing
it's because you are a conspiracy
theorist
with all the republicans are talking
about like critical race theory and
they're making this huge
deal about it and it's all the
conversation and the news with virginia
like what are you gonna say
to all those people making education
about that uh that's another right-wing
conspiracy
this is uh totally made up by donald
trump and glenn young
this is who they are it's a conspiracy
theory oh it's a conspiracy theory weird
then it's being adopted
and praised in the pages of the new york
times and also that there are so many
open proponents of it in the halls of
power
in the united states strange strange
it's a conspiracy theory it seems like
the conspiracy is kind of real
considering how many
major players are out defending critical
race theory today charles blow being one
of the latest
in the opinion pages of the new york
times just demonstrates understand
critical race theory suggests
that all of america's core institutional
tenets all of our basic values of the
declaration of independence they are
lies
that really those are just a guise for
white supremacist power politics
it's all about upholding the power of
whiteness
it's all about upholding the systems of
power in the united states and all this
talk about individual rights and freedom
of speech and freedom of the press and
freedom of religion freedom of so
all those freedoms are basically just a
lie designed to keep people of color
down which is weird because in the
united states
asian americans are the highest earning
income group nigerian americans are
extraordinarily high earning income
group far higher than white americans
so apparently the institutions meant to
elevate white people actually kind of
suck in the united states at this point
but put all of that aside the idea is
that
everything at root is about power right
there's no such thing as principle is
the theory
of critical race theory all those
principles are a lie
it is all about power now the dirty
secret is that critical race theory
itself
is an attempt to regain power it is not
about principle it is not about
establishing
some high-minded principle of equity it
is simply about
who wields power against whom which is
why they are so
darned upset if you try to define their
terms and if you say okay i want you to
explain to me what critical race theory
is so that i can actually
understand it and then accept or reject
it they get very angry at you
and even if you've read all of their
works even if you read richard delgado
even if you read
gene stephan check even if you read
derek bell right which i have in law
school
even if you've read all of those things
they will still say you know you
misunderstand and the reason they always
say this
notice this is a common tactic on the
left refusal to define terms if i even
have to define it you just don't know
right they do the same thing with the
term woman if you say okay it seems like
the term woman that you're constantly
using to talk about like how important
it is that kamala harris is a woman for
example
it seems like that term is utterly
malleable considering that men who
identify as women you also consider
women so please define women they'll be
like
if you don't know then i'm not going to
explain it to you
the last refuge of the intellectual
scoundrel and so so the left does this
all the time
they don't want to define terms because
terms language is a tool of power
this is pure michel foucault foucault
suggested that language was basically
just a weapon
okay and the left believes this
everything they suggest about the right
is true of the left everything they
suggest about the right that we have
principles but that those principles
aren't principles
they're really just power that we that
we are merely using words as cudgels
this is
all the left does all day it is just
projection it is pure
projection james lindsey says this the
the
the professor he is correct about this
it is in fact
just projection it is pure projection so
charles blows a perfect example of this
so he will say that all of america's
high-minded principles those are really
just cover for power
but also critical race theory is not
just a cover for power critical race
theory is a higher ideal
but if you attempt to define it they're
not going to let you
because i sort of like the power
structure that is embedded in critical
race theory
in a second we'll get to charles blow
trying to obfuscate the issue
because again in the obfuscation lies
the ability to
beat to political death your opponents
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the most comfortable
office chair in all the land
i of course am speaking of the fantastic
x-chair
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support
dvl support it offers unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back
now thanks to their new xhmt technology
you can also get heat and massage
therapy while you you're sitting
at your desk i mean it's like heaven in
a chair instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair now you can
look forward to spending hours sitting
in the ultimate therapeutic massager our
producers fight over it during the show
i can actually hear them throwing fists
at one another to see who gets to sit
in the x chair the x hmc delivers heat
and massage technology right to your
core helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy
all the perks that make working from
home or the office a joy x chair is on
sale right now for a hundred bucks off
go to xchairshapiro.com right now
that's the letter x chair s-h-a-p-i-r-o
dot com
or call one eight four four four x-chair
x-chair has a 30-day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month go to
ex-chairshapiro.com right now use codex
wheels for free
xwheel bladecasters xchairshapiro.com
gets the greatest
of all chairs now if you're an american
you've probably noticed a few things
happening lately
you know like spending a year locked in
your home force masking the ideological
indoctrination that is surging through
our school system corporations
government
if you're like me you probably care
about stopping it you feel like you are
living in an increasingly
authoritarian state well that is why i
wrote the authoritarian moment to help
you understand how our culture got to
this point
and how you can fight it the
authoritarian moment is coming out on
july 27th
but you can order it early right now it
is a really important book it talks
about
why you feel the way you do the reason
you feel the way you do is because it
ain't in your head
it's reality every major institution in
our society has been twisted toward
leftist authoritarianism
cram downs quashing of descent you need
to know how that happened so that we can
reverse it i talk in the book the
authoritarian moment about how to
reverse it how to fight back
it requires concerted and intelligent
action the authoritarian moment is now
available for pre-order
at amazon barnes noble or any other
major bookseller
a lot of people make the journey from
the left to the right for good reason
the left is undeniably growing more
insane by the day
some of you who leave the left have
documented it via the walk away series
on youtube if you've seen them it's
likely you've watched the video of
georgia hal
former teacher and liberal who's brought
her expertise on ideological
indoctrination from the classroom to the
daily wire
she has started her very own show office
hours you can now listen to that no
matter where you are in podcast form
whether she's discussing critical race
theory with the aforementioned james
lindsay or transgenderism with abigail
schreier her show offers a wealth of
incredible information from some of
america's most important
and underutilized voices so subscribe
and download
office hours with georgia hal on apple
podcast or whatever your platform of
choice may be get ready for the ultimate
listening experience no matter where
you are you are listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so charles blow of the new york
times one of the worst columnists over
there but one of the beautiful things
about being a bad columnist for the new
york times is sometimes you
make clear what the truth is so blow has
a piece today in the new york times
title demonizing a critical race theory
the fact that the entire democratic
party feels the necessity to defend
critical race theory says something
about its importance to them
so says charles blow critical race
theory is the political rights new
boogeyman
the theory born in the 1970s among legal
scholars uses race as a lens through
which to examine structures of power
it was i would argue a relatively
obscure concept not because it lacked
merit but because it was novel
now you may notice again his definition
here is just wrong it is not just
he's not defining the theory he says the
theory is he uses race as a lens okay
but that's not
a theory the theory is like a theory
like what does it theorize about the
world like we all understand that
race matters but what is that what
exactly does that have to do
with how you examine the world okay so
says charles blow critical race theory
was simply an analytical tool
but some white people the fact that
white supremacy was overtly used to
infect american systems of power with
both racial oppressions and racial
privileges
is too much to handle it is
discomforting it unravels the american
myth okay so this is where he
he moves beyond his vague definition and
gets a little more specific right he
moves beyond
critical race theory is just a way to
look at the law you know you look at
race and the law and the relationship
between them
instead he just lets the cat out of the
bag what is critical race theory
critical race theory is the fact that
white supremacy was overtly used to
infect america's
systems of power with racial oppressions
and racial privileges
he says critical race theory doesn't
diagnose the country as evil even though
it is beyond dispute that some evil
people design the architecture
of racial oppression and that there are
still some who helped maintain it in
fact
i don't even believe that most people
have any real concept of what critical
race theory is
it's just a collection of words that
hint to them at an agitation and
agreement
a theory that mentions race and that is
critical or in their mind criticizes
critical race theory began to stand for
any teachings that challenged the
narrative that white america had crafted
about the country
and that unveiled any truths that it had
tried to hide or raise okay so now what
the left is trying to do
is they're trying to say that if you
object to the idea that all of america's
institutions of power
are shot through with racism today and
that racism is buried
so deep in the substructure of american
life that it has to be torn out by the
roots all of those structures have to be
torn out by the roots
if you oppose that it's because you
don't want to teach kids about slavery
or something
okay what is the real goal here the real
goal here is to be able to press forward
the agenda
right and and charles blow pretty much
makes this clear
he makes clear that he just wants what
he wants
and if you attack critical race theory
then you're a racist
right it's a it's a full martin bailey
argument right they put out an argument
they say critical race theory the
argument is that america's
basically racist like from its inception
through all of its institutions it's
racist you say that's not true
and then they were true true oh you
don't want to tell the truth about
america
which means you're a racist of course
and because you're a racist i should get
to make all the policy
says charles blow this attack on
critical race theory is no different
than the rush during the obama
administration by states to ban sharia
law in state courts
this is simply an extension of the
barack obama is a secret muslim
conspiracy
and the backlash to his presence in the
white house oh that's what this is
or alternatively some of us actually
read critical race theory and we know
what it is
and it's bad okay but the fact is that
again
all of this sort of stuff the ideology
for the left is a tool of power
it is not about higher principle it is
just about coalition building
and tools of power how can you tell
because certain types of commentary are
fine according to the left even if they
violate
the intersectional structures of the
left it just depends who's doing it
hey so to take a perfect example
yesterday chuck schumer who's a useful
person right there's a division
on the left between people who are
useful and people who are not that's all
it is not who is right and who is wrong
it's who is useful and who is not
chuck schumer is still useful because
chuck schumer of course
is the senate majority leader so
yesterday he was doing a show
and he used the word and now
we've been told over and over and over
that use of the word
particularly when you're referring
specifically to people with down
syndrome for example
that that is not allowed right it is
uncouth it is
ugly it is a slower right this is what
we've been to most of us have been
trained on this for the last couple of
decades or so it's pretty common to hear
kids throw this around the playground in
like 1993
not so common to hear kids throw this
around the playground in like 2021.
chuck schumer just throws it out there
the media
said that chuck schumer's use of the
word right
his use of that word here to refer
specifically to children with down
syndrome
his use of that word was not a slur it
was not a slur
it was just uncomfortable it was
outmoded
the word that political use was outmoded
here is chuck schumer being outmoded
and when i first was assemblyman they
wanted to build a congregate living
place for children
the old neighborhood was against it
these are harmless kids they just needed
some help
we got it done okay again no blowback
outmoded use some outmoded language now
imagine if a republican use that word ah
the world comes crashing down but again
chuck schumer the the word the
inconsistency is the point
okay it's the feature not the bug it is
not that the left are a bunch of
hypocrites that they have no standards
the standards are merely a tool they
hold you to account okay but the
standards don't apply to them this is
why hunter biden can use the n-word as
much as he could possibly want
no problem but if a 17-year-old girl
used the n-word
with an a at the end imitating a rapper
when she was 15 and got her driver's
permit the new york times will run a 4
000 word piece and she will lose
her scholarship slot in cheerleading at
the university of tennessee
right the standard only applies to one
side of the aisle because it is
just a way to beat you to death
everybody on the right understands this
by the way
you want to know why the wright embraced
trump because they said we're not going
to hold by any of your standards now the
proper answer
would have been some of those standards
are bad and some are good and let's try
and figure out which are good and which
are bad and hold everybody to accounts
across the board
but instead what the right did is a
fairly predictable thing they said your
standards are
we know your standards are bold and
because we know your standards are bull
we're going to elect this guy and you
know what he doesn't obey any of your
standards tear down all the standards
which is a rather understandable
response if not a fully morally
justified one
and because the left doesn't have any
standards it's not about hypocrisy it's
about they don't have standards except
standards to which they hold
you to account another perfect example
so yesterday
marjorie taylor green the controversial
republican congresswoman
from georgia who said a bunch of crazy
things about jewish space lasers in the
past and then she
made a weird comment comparing the and i
thought
ridiculous comment comparing mask
wearing uh or or businesses that suggest
that you should have to wear masks when
you walk in if you're unvaccinated
to the holocaust right so she went she
visited the holocaust center in
washington d.c now this is normally what
we demand of our politicians right
in fact i recall that there was a
democratic politician in washington dc
who said that the jews control the
weather and then he went and visited the
holocaust museum
and he came out and made an apology and
everybody's like okay done
okay so marjorie taylor did the same
thing she went to the holocaust museum
in washington dc and she came out and
she made a statement
the horrors of the holocaust are
something that
some people don't even believe happened
and some people deny but there is no
comparison to the holocaust
and there are words that i have said
remarks that i've made
that i know are offensive and for that i
want to apologize
and i am i am just fine
and very glad to be able to come out
here and do that because i believe it's
important
i believe that if we're going to leave
we need to be able to lead in a way
where if we've messed up it's very
important for us to say we're sorry
okay so she goes she says she's sorry
she openly apologizes for the comments
listen well taken all right meanwhile
steve cohen democratic congress person
he comes out he's like not enough not
enough for marjorie taylor green
no i i refuse to accept the apology she
didn't learn
uh much about uh
really the experience the holocaust she
sounded like she had some phrases that
she saw
maybe somebody told her about the worst
genocide ever something would never
happen again or never forget
but it didn't sound like it came from
the heart okay
i'm sorry so the democratic party
watches martial they just strip margaret
taylor green of all of her committee
assignments right over these comments
and so marjorie taylor green lost her
committee assignments she went to the
holocaust museum she apologized
ilhan omar is a wild open anti-semite
rashida toledo is a wild open
anti-semite they
again every other day they just say
something about how much they hate jews
basically
and the entire democratic party is like
well
and then they quote unquote clarify and
nancy pelosi will give you well you know
it's all good it's all good you know
well there's nothing to talk about
case closed she's still on the foreign
affairs committee so here's
is the point that i'm making with
regards to the left it's all about
the power it is not about fundamental
principle it's about how they gain and
maintain power
i do not accept the honesty of the
principles they supposedly promulgate
i think they are lying to you i think
they are lying to me
i think that if they believe this stuff
they're lying to themselves i don't
think that they hold any of these
standards
i think that when people are convenient
then they get to outlive
their their bad act and when they are
inconvenient then we just dispose of
them
and just to flex their power every so
often you'll see the left just
get somebody to issue an apology for no
reason at all right so ilhan omar never
issued an apology for anything she's
ever said
but the left will force lin-manuel
miranda to offer his latest apology so
remember lin-manuel miranda
has been forced to sort of offer
apologies for having written hamilton
how dare he not make slavery the key
issue
in the founding of the united states in
hamilton and he had to issue some some
apologies for that well now lin-manuel
miranda is having to issue apologies for
in the heights
which is a racially diverse musical
about
people in crown heights
in new york who are of minority
persuasion
what did he do wrong according to
variety.com
lin-manuel miranda is now addressing
criticism over the film's lack of
afro-latino representation
in a statement posted to twitter miranda
apologized for not including more
dark-skinned afro-latinos in the film's
cast especially in the leading roles
i started writing in the heights because
i didn't feel seen and over the past 20
years all i wanted was for us all of us
to feel seen miranda's statement begins
i'm seeing the discussion around after
latino representation in our film this
weekend
it is clear many in our dark skinned
afro-latino community don't feel
sufficiently represented within it
particularly among the leading roles
the discussion miranda mentioned stems
from a video article in the root
published on wednesday which points out
there are no dark-skinned afro-latinos
in the film's leading roles
so very important for him to apologize
now
miranda ended his statement by saying he
would try to do better
in the future try to do better in the
future meanwhile the left is trying to
cuddle apologies
out of tom hanks because tom hanks is
not sufficiently anti-racist he's just
not a racist
so npr ran an op-ed from a person named
eric degens titled tom hanks
is a non-racist it's time for him to be
anti-racist see they're just going to
cuddle you into the corner
if you are a person who is a lifelong
democrat but you have not done
sufficient
work you have not done the work they
will cuddle you into the corner because
again it is not
about principle it's about power
politics it's about getting people on
board for whatever your radical agenda
is today
this article is is pretty much a master
class in this eric degens over at npr he
writes
first i must note how much i love tom
hanks as a performer hollywood citizen
an all-around stand-up guy
of course he's a consummate actor with
two oscars and starring roles in
landmark films such as philadelphia and
forrest gump
he's been an outspoken advocate for gay
rights and environmentalism
so when i saw he had recently written a
guest essay for the new york times
calling for more widespread teaching
about the tulsa race massacre
i was sincerely heartened now i thought
we'll see him examine how his work
so often focused on the achievements of
virtuous white
male americans may have made it tougher
for tales about atrocities such as tulsa
to find similar space you see
it turns out saving private ryan was not
about tulsa but it should have been
about tulsa
so tom hanks is a bad white man
but says eric diggins he didn't fully go
there here's what he did say quote
history was mostly written by white
people about white people like me
while the history of black people
including the horrors of tulsa was too
often left out
until relatively recently the
entertainment industry which helps shape
what is history and what has forgotten
did the same
that includes projects of mine then he
goes on to say he learned of tulsa from
an article in the new york times last
year
and another line later in the piece
today i think historically based fiction
entertainment must portray the burden of
racism in our nation for the sake of the
art form's claims to various
varisimilitude and authenticity says
eric diggins these are wise words
but it is not enough he built a career
playing righteous white men
after many years of speaking out about
race and media in america i know the
toughest thing for some white americans
is to admit how they were personally and
specifically connected to the elevation
of white culture above other cultures
but in hanks's case he's no average
american or average hollywood star for
that matter
over the years he has starred in a lot
of big movies about historical events
including saving private ryan
greyhound forrest gump apollo 13 bridge
of spies and news of the world
he has served as producer or executive
producer on even more films and tv shows
based on american history
including band of brothers the pacific
john adams and from the earth to the
moon
in other words he's a baby boomer star
who has built a sizable part of his
career on stories about american white
men
doing the right thing but the stories
often leave out
black contributions they often leave out
how black soldiers returned home from
fighting in world war ii to find out
they weren't allowed to use the gi bill
to secure home loans in certain
neighborhoods or were cheated out of
claiming benefits at all so let's just
be clear this guy is now angry at tom
hanks
because saving private ryan didn't end
with a black member of the platoon going
home and being rejected from the gi bill
which would have fit seamlessly into the
plot of the film
obviously he should have done that no
tom hanks must be cudgelled
it's the difference between being a
non-racist and being an anti-racist
he's saying it's time for folks like
hanks
to be quote-unquote anti-racist if he
really wants to make a difference hanks
and other stars need to talk
specifically
about how their work has contributed to
these problems and how
they will change it's all about now
struggle sessions it's
all about power that's what we're
focused on here at home who can we
cuddle is doing what the left wants
not confronting foreign adversaries not
strengthening america
how can we cudgel other americans into
doing what we want politically by
upholding standards that are completely
hypocritical
and utterly inconsistent on every level
that's where we are so good luck to us
over the next few years
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt welsh show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show